le dicton du jour à la saint médard
france 2 fait débattre messieurs giscard
et rocard bonsoir messieurs
est ce qu'il n'ya pas avant de parler du
fond des dossiers un petit peu une
erreur de casting vous monsieur giscard
d'estaing on a l'impression que vous
piaffez de ne pas mener une campagne qui
piétinent un peu et vous monsieur rocard
on se demande certains soirs si vous
n'avez pas le regret d'être monté dans
cette galère est-ce que vous ne
regrettez pas de ne pas mener campagne
du tout on avait ce que nous avons faire
on a sept interroge et qu'il fallait
faire une liste de liste souvenez de ce
débat qu'il est est ce que le
journaliste ont suivi ce débat et puis
finalement la prochaine dans les chairs
croissance actuelle qui sont
particulières la cohabitation donc là la
situation politique de la france en même
temps la situation de l'europe il valait
mieux qui est une liste commune unique
et on a posé trois en principe premier
principe c'est d'abord un programme pour
cette liste devront donc un projet qui
notre projet pour commun pour l'europe
puis des f rpr nous avons dit on va y
revenir tout à l'heure parce que c'est
très important que tous les députés à
les piéger dans le même groupe le
contenu ppe au parlement européen elle a
vendu enfin qu'il fallait une liste
unique alors à partir de ce moment là
des mots c'est pas candidat pour
conduire cette tête de liste pour noise
ont tout à fait simple mettez
représentait l'année dernière dans ma
circonscription dans le puy-de-dôme et
c'est le parrainant après faire espèce
de valse-hésitation de la fièvre de
l'autre et donc s'il fallait trouver une
nouvelle tête de lice alors on a choisi
par la voie démocratique on a voté on a
désigné un homme aux jeunes croyants à
l'europe maire de toulouse dominique
baudis rx grande villa campagne et mon
rôle comme celui de jacques chirac on a
bu comme celui d'edouard balladur c'est
d'appuyer cette campagne soutenir cette
campagne met naturellement c'est la tête
de lice qui l'a conduit michel rocard
vous avez fait allusion à la tempête est
ce que vous ne regrettez pas certains
soirs d'été sur ce bateau vous
garantissez ou à prendre absolument pas
y avait des coups à prendre mais j'ai la
vie ted et la tempête ça convient au
maroc comme vous savez
c'était une bataille très nécessaire il
ma tâche bien avant de penser à des
perspectives plus lointaine est une
tâche de reconstruction de
reconstructeurs d'espoir et de
reconstructeurs à gauche d'une force
organisée il était indispensable que je
conduise cette bataille faute de quoi
tout le reste pouvait être compromis
je suis heureux de l'amener mais en
effet c'est la tempête cela étant il me
semble que l'électorat commence à sentir
de voir que nous sommes la liste la plus
sérieusement européenne il ya un tiers
d'anti européen farouche sur la liste de
monsieur baudis
on s'explique d'ailleurs l'insuffisance
de certaines de ses propositions ou
l'absence même de propositions moi je
suis fier de ce combat et je pense que
nous en récolterons les fruits sous
giscard d'estaing je vous ai posé la
même question la mission car il ya
quelques jours qu'il avait fait rire est
ce que vous avez est ce que vous êtes un
maastricht n'étaient pas du tout j'ai
fait campagne commune sauvé pour la
ratification du traité de maastricht
gens connaissaient les limites on
connaissait les défauts bien sûr mais
c'était un progrès pour l'europe et
simplement revenons en arrière d'un an
et demi imaginez que le référendum en
france plus été négatif que les français
et 10 et 10 non leur en serai par terre
nous sommes en train de commémorer on
entendra peut-être tout à l'heure le 50e
anniversaire du débarquement c'est à
dire de la guerre pour des jolies gens
de ma génération ce trade émouvant bon
les autres quand ils n'ont pas connu sa
motion se réveiller un matin on a dit
les alliés ont débarqué ce formidable
bond et ses concessionnaires très fort
imaginez qu'on commémore le débarquement
et qui ont dix ans après l'europe et les
porter nous avons voté non à maastricht
a plus l'europe
imaginez ce que serait cette année les
rencontres franco allemand de climat de
notre continent
donc en effet je suis pas du tout à
maastricht ya honteux dans quoi je vous
dirai tout à l'heure et il en fait
d'ailleurs le reproche à michel rocard
sont quelquefois je considère que ce
qu'on a fait au cours des dernières
années a comporté des fautes en europe
et je crois qu'il faut continuer
différents dans le progrès de l'europe
alors certains de vos adversaires
notamment monsieur le pen 10 dans les
meetings la liste baudis alice toro car
c'est blanc bonnet et bonnet blanc alors
c'est peut-être l'occasion ce soir de
voir ce qui vous sépare vraiment et
notamment en matière en matière d'emploi
parce que les sondages montrent que s'il
ya bien un domaine où les français ont
cent
manque l'europe n'a pas vraiment
fonctionné c'est sur l'emploi alors je
voudrais vous poser très simplement la
question est très concrètement vous ne
serez pas si j'aurai pas à strasbourg
mais qu'est ce que peut faire très
concrètement le parlement de strasbourg
pour débloquer la situation
d'abord il faut l'évacuer style soit en
de bonnet blanc et blanc bonnet c'est un
point sur lequel je suis d'accord pour
que je mette grande différence entre un
si bel avion non avaler jean-marie le
pen a siégé à strasbourg et au parlement
qui sait bien qu'à deux grands groupes
au parlement
le groupe socialiste qui comprenait à
peu près de 100 députés a essayé
franchir la barre des 200 députés et le
groupe du centre droit qu'on appelle le
dpe parti populaire on repère dans
lequel je siégeais qu'elle va à peu près
160 députés et de passer à 175 180
évidemment c'est entre ces deux grands
groupes que ce fait le débat européen
ou bien on va dans la direction
socialiste ou bien on va dans la
direction libéral ne s'est pas la même
chose
donc il en faisant le même bâtiment
c'est vrai c'est l'europe
quant à la dépendance et le parlement
européen mais on y est pour défendre des
thèses différentes j'imagine que michel
rocard il défendra la tête socialiste
c'est quand j siège est quand demain de
mélodies si evra nous défendons les
thèses libérales alors sur l'emploi de
mots simplement pas j'aime moins
débattre d'ailleurs tout à l'heure avec
michel rocard parce que j'ai entendu
faire ses propositions et je voudrais
lui dire combien elle dans ce désaccord
est certainement mais il ya le niveau il
ya le niveau européen et au niveau
national vous savez qu'en europe et un
peu près 11 % de chômeurs de la
population active ya les pays en a plus
y en a moins les pays en a plus sélect
elle principalement l'espagne a le plus
de chômeurs en europe
et puis ensuite la france et l'italie et
puis les autres un peu mois parmi les
grands pays et l'allemagne
beaucoup moins donc les pays qui en
europe pour le plus de chômage cdp
conduit une direction socialiste depuis
dix ans alors qu'elle est notre objectif
faire baisser la moyenne en europe
c'est là que le show soit 11 en europe
sa baisse et sont peu baissé de moitié
en cinq ans et vivant ça ferait un très
bon résultat
et puis en france par rapport à la
moyenne améliorer notre notre résultat
et ça c'est une affaire française on
vous dirait sur le plan de leur prêt
s'il faut faire deux choses il faut
faire des grands travaux
on les connaît on va dire les décide
et dans quelques jours simplement il a
fallu deux gens pour le faire parce
qu'il faut prendre les légions au début
dcri ce n'est pas la fin parce qu'alpha
ne sert plus à rien or la crise elle
date remonte à 91 on a fait un sommet à
edimbourg la fin de cette année là on
est à 94 on attend toujours
ça montre bien que l'europe ne marche
pas très bien il va falloir l'améliorer
et ensuite il faut faire ces travaux
correspondant aux besoins en grandes
infrastructures pour la france et 3 de
projet de tgv qui sont dans le programme
est le cas pourquoi il n'a pas répondu
quand il était premier ministre
à vallet trop lui demandait de faire un
tgv pour l'eau vers les clés jamais eu
de réponse revanche signé l'appel par
rapport à la mise en oeuvre du schéma à
la mise en route d'un schéma directeur
des tgv alors est ce que tu es
gouvernance et voilà mais je reviens sur
cette affaire dont au niveau européen un
programme de grands travaux iphone c'est
assez d'accord et puis la convergence
des politiques c'est à dire essayer
d'avoir tout de même une politique
économique commune une monnaie commune
pourquoi vis-à-vis de l'extérieur
l'europe se défendent mieux et puis la
deuxième chose ça c'est l'europe
et la deuxième chose c'est qu'il faudra
un programme très actif en france pour
rattraper les rangs pays comparables
grimpent est incomparable à l'heure
actuelle dans laquelle se basent entre 6
et 7 dans taux de chômage supérieur 11
là c'est une politique de la france
michelin car oui commençons par
redresser une information les pays qui
ont le plus de chômage en europe sont
ceux qui ont plus d'enfants
l'espagne et la france ont une
démographie bien meilleur que
l'allemagne
c'est aussi avec l'armée au début mais
chiche et la démographie européenne
actuellement en espagne derrière nous et
elle est derrière la grande bretagne
mais elle est devant l'allemagne et ça
fait la différence
vous le savez très bien sûr cela je vous
en prie et en plus pour corriger
faussement ils se lisent la référence
est un organe ou non vous parlez anglais
du monde
continuons le programme de grands
travaux nous le souhaitons tous je les
demande et puissamment on est entrain
d'ergoter sur cinq milliards dès qu par
an je voudrais dire tu as un mot que
leur produit d'une richesse annuelle de
6500 n'y avait que nous ne sommes pas
dans les proportions
nous vivons en effet un chômage
intolérable et il faut multiplier les
efforts
j'appelle nouvelle donne européenne tous
ses efforts et l'exigent deux choses la
première c'est d'améliorer les
procédures de fonctionnement en effet
tout c'est beaucoup trop long mais la
seconde chance c'est d'en prendre le
calibre est le moyen et pour ma part je
propose un effort de 50 milliards des
culs ce qui est une somme petit ce n'est
même pas 1% du produit national brut
communautaire bien moins que ça c'est
une somme raisonnable
devant ce problème du chômage qui
ravagent des destins entier qui ravagent
des villes et des banlieues qui
détruisent l'espérance dans ce pays qui
des qualifi tant de gens on ne peut pas
ne rien faire
l'acceptation du statut quo un mini
programme ou si mince ça n'a pas de sens
et jeudi sur ce sujet tout simple que
c'est la déraison que de ne pas m'être
l'ambition de son côté la raison veut
qu'on donne priorité à cette lutte
contre le chômage
et puis un problème de plus comment on
finance vous n'avez jamais dit je suis
d'accord mois pour que l'europe prenne
de risques d'un emprunt nécessite
permettant de financer en partie ses
chantiers ces grands travaux auxquels
d'ailleurs je veux ajouter pas seulement
les infrastructures mais la
réhabilitation générale de boue des
banlieues en europe
or en plus ces travaux vont produire de
la richesse c'est sur cette richesse
qu'on remboursera donc notre dispositif
éclair et nous sommes très choqués je
suis très choqué de ce qu'il y a deux
jours le conseil des ministres est
encore réduit le volume de l'initiative
européenne de croissance car je signale
que cette idée initialement c'est une
idée de jacques delors qui se trouvent
être des nôtres nous pensons bien dans
le même sens il faut que l'europe prenne
ses responsabilités un journal titrait
l'europe en panne
nous voulons la remettre en marche et il
en est grande et il faut en prendre les
moyens et le volume
vous parlez de toutes petites choses
jamais entendu cette proposition qui va
provoquer de milites baudis dans son ire
réaliste oui 50 plusieurs pourquoi pas
100 milliards pour 200 lui apporter
alors et en réaliste et qu'au dessus en
effet il faut se prêter les unes
personne ne sait ce que c'est que 50
milliards ou 100 milliards personal
avant sa poche qu'est ce que c'est le
budget de la communauté à l'heure
actuelle c'est 70 milliards par an
parlant des culs 70 milliards alors vous
dites on va rajouter 50 milliards
pourquoi faire payer par qui
lorsqu'elle le débat à edimbourg faits
remontaient à edimbourg la france était
représentée par des socialistes c'est le
président mitterrand et c'était le
premier ministre socialiste de l'époque
on avait déjà parlé de 50 ou 100
milliards je crois même que françois
mitterrand avait cité quelque part le
chiffre de 100 milliards il ya eu une
discussion il ya un accord j'ai l'accord
tous les yeux que si l'on fait si le 100
milliards s'appliquait sur plusieurs
empreintes sur voilà on s'est perdus en
parlant du premier si c'est parfaitement
clair
bon alors vous aimez les enfants d'aller
voir ces fameux 50 pays alors 10 50
mille ha par an pour un budget de 70 ans
pour les gens qui gèrent une
collectivité locale une petite
entreprise on leur dit on va faire
passer vos dépenses de la lys 70 alain
10120 donc faire ça pendant 58 médailles
or il faut savoir qu'on a discuté ce qu
est le manque on a recensé les projets
saas et les projets et on a trouvé comme
projet au total 20 milliards des culs
parra dont on a besoin de dépenser
valiant on a fait trente ans que j'étais
pas tous les pays sont dits d'accord il
ya là dedans déposé important et elle
tgv est pour la france les clients
jusqu'à strasbourg passants étaient
rares et vosges il ya le tgb du midi
elle tgv lyon milan il yad'autres
d'opération des actions de l'espagne etc
on avait tous recensement et ça fait 20
milliards des culs parents comment les
finances ton on prend sur les finances
les fameux 70 miller qu'on a on prend
chaque milliard c'est vrai on emprunte
la banque européenne d'investissement
enfin pour faire 7 milliards il manque
lui mais là on va faire un nouvel
emprunt de vue bizarre ça fait donc là
milliard par an et on fait tout ça c'est
sans impôts parce que les sharks avaient
récupéré bon vos empreintes toujours pas
pourquoi d'ailleurs actuellement tout le
monde peut emprunter il n'y a pas de
limite de la possibilité d'emprunter en
raison de des liquidités dans le monde
on peut emprunter la question de savoir
qui rembourse
or les hausses des dépenses de l'europe
elles sont plafonnées 199 par un accord
signé françois mitterrand n'était plus
premier ministre vous avez remplacé on a
cet accord et elles sont actuellement de
1 1% peu importe le chiffre du pib
maintenant elles vont être 1,27 en 99
ses programmes et donc on ne va pas
pouvoir payer les intérêts
tendre sociaux ont fait un impôt et moi
je peux la question à michel rocard il
sait comment ça se passe les votes
parlement européen en un petit n'est pas
siéger jusqu'à présent voilà les sièges
et bientôt alors vous aurez devant vous
un petit bloc donc selon un autre d'une
carte comme une carte de crédit et on a
trois boutons pour compte
abstention dans votre système il faudra
créer un impôt européen est d'ailleurs
dans votre programme vous dit le
parlement pourra créer un impôt européen
moi je vous pose la question s'il ya une
proposition pour créer un impôt européen
il avait dix secondes pour voter aux
banques est-ce que vous appuyez sur pour
est-ce que vous appuyez sur contre si
vous appuyez sur l'abstention
moi je voterai contre nous venons
d'entendre c'est admirable discours de
la résignation
je voudrais attirer l'attention de nos
amis téléspectateurs sur le fait que
nous sommes dans l'impuissance justifier
ce qui est tout de même considérable et
à c'est inadmissible et je rappelle en
plus exclusive le rappelle est cruel
mais tout de même que je n'accepte pas
vos leçons sur le chômage il y avait
quatre cent mille chômeurs en france
quand vous avez été élu président de la
république il y en avait 1 million 600
mille quand vous avez quitté vos
fonctions ce qui montre bien que le
problème était énorme dimension et que
vous n'avez pas été meilleur que nous
pour le traiter c'est bien pour ça qu'il
faut accélérer pousser les feux et je
réponds très clairement on rembourse un
emprunt sur une croissance à n'importe
qui c'est ça un chef d'entreprise quand
il veut acheter une machine il emprunte
et avec quoi et en bourse il rembourse
avec la richesse produite par la machine
c'est aussi simple il faut en effet en
finir par un nouvel accord avec le
plafonnement actuel du budget européen
et et voir les restitutions des états
augmenté grâce à la croissance de
richesse que cela permettra on doit
d'après nos calculs sont tirés sans
impôt nouveau mais je ne serais pas
choqué qu'un jour vienne un impôt
européen parce que le budget de la
communauté ridiculement faible c'est en
effet dérisoire de mettre nos espoirs
pour l'avenir dans une europe puissante
et dont le budget représente à peine un
peu plus que le total de toute la
richesse qu'elle produit
mais nous avons du temps et je dis moi
pour le moment que l'europe a la
responsabilité
d'entamer une vraie bataille contre le
chômage veut accélérer la croissance et
c'est la croissance qui nous permettra
de rembourser chacun de vie excusez moi
monsieur giscard d'estaing bbc peut
dépasser poumons son temps de parole et
on est tenu à des équipes donc leur
poser une question monsieur routeur pour
pour maintenir l'équilibré puis je vous
propose à vous deux de balayer un
maximum de questions pour que les
téléspectateurs qui sont aussi des
électeurs puissent se faire une opinion
n'a plus de la plus ferme possible sur
un ensemble de sujets qui sont parfois
un peu incompréhensible commun des
mortels alors la grande question c'est
l'élargissement de l'europe aux pays de
anciennement socialistes à l'est alors
est-ce que selon vous il faut admettre
rapidement ces pays de l'est arriver une
europe qui pourrait être une europe à 26
et quel en serait le prix à payer ne
serait-ce qu'en contribution il faut
trois choses dira rapidement à tout
peuple installés en europe qu'il a
vocation à faire partie de l'union
européenne
deuxièmement ne pas provoquer de
nouveaux élargissements après les trois
scandinaves et l'autriche
sans avoir amélioré le fonctionnement
interne de l'europe sans la voir
renforcée je propose pour cela
reprenant d'ailleurs un travail déjà
commencé au parlement européen on écrive
et qu'on soumette au référendum dans
toute l'europe à la fois la constitution
de fait les règles du jeu soient perd on
sache qui fait quoi et conserve surtout
ce que l'europe ne fait pas car il est
vrai qu'il lui est arrivé de se mêler de
trop de choses ce n'est pas un point
qu'ils fassent divergences entre nous
pour les pays de l'est
il faut que leur sécurité soit acquise
ils ont vocation à nous rejoindre
il faut que les règles du jeu en leur
soient présentés mais il faudra de
longues transition économique
entrez dans un marché vraiment commun
avec des pays aussi puissant le maillot
de la france d'aujourd'hui
c'est pour eux dangereux et dès que le
principe sera acquis eux-mêmes demandons
de longue transition mais l'europe a
vocation à rassembler tout le monde
prenons nous y bien pour le moment
mettons de l'ordre dans les affaires
européennes jusqu'à destin quels termes
plus j'ai été un chaud partisan de
l'adhésion de la suède de la norvège de
l'autriche et de la finlande
les quatre pays d'europe qui ont été
longtemps et deux d'entre eux le sont
toujours
direction socialiste où il ya le moins
de chômage encore un autre démenti votre
réflexion tout à l'heure et oui à la
meilleure protection sociale
c'est avec cela que l'europe sociale
sera tirée par le haut et c'est avec
leur volonté car il arrive pour
participer à une europe puissante
sinon ils sont déjà dans vous êtes
contre la ratification de ces quatre
nouveaux pays avait d'abord on a entendu
des valeurs sur 40 euros perçus de
manière un peu des impôts en france je
les en a qu'il soit nécessaire ne me
faites pas dire ce que je n'ai pas dit
mais vas-y noir retrouvons j'ai dit que
en remboursant un emprunt sur la
richesse que le yach mais on suivra vos
gonds franc avec vous permettent de
créer mais je ne serai pas changer
l'avenir il nous faudra bien renforcer
l'europe et cela passera par sa propre
fiscalité
je pense que c'est pour le prochain
millénaire je ne pense pas que ce soit
sa fonction les larges zones
avant que le poisson il ya cinq ans sur
sa l'avenir 8 roubles 1 pourquoi êtes
vous contre la ratification ne leur ai
dit les choses d'être mis l'humain peut
agresser tout à l'heure c'est normal
qu'un débat pouvait inquiéter les
spectateurs l'annulation est l'un
d'entre eux et c'est votre question
premier mauvais coup cet été laissant de
l'agriculture pourquoi à l'heure
actuelle y at il des français qui
étaient les plus européens et qui sont
les moins européen c'est les
agriculteurs et c'est dû au fait que on
a fait à 81,12 vous n'étiez plus premier
ministre c'est encore le gouvernement
socialiste
et c'est elle votre ministre de
l'agriculture juste aimé remet à ce que
vous aviez nommé qui étaient là qui a
accepté une réforme de la politique
agricole commune qui a transformé les
agriculteurs pro européen en adversaire
de l'europe dans tous les sondages
actuels vous pouvez regarder la
catégorie qui va voter
no - saveurs de l'europe ce sont les
agriculteurs prom attisée par la réforme
de la politique agricole commune
ça a été un mauvais coup socialistes
contre l'europe
le deuxième volet gourmand tout de suite
oui nos chars pour la carte vidéo
cette manière de voir les choses ni
produit depuis que la politique agricole
commune existe les états unis la
combattent et essaye de la démo
ils ont fait une énorme pression pour
inclure l'agriculture dans des
négociations qui visait à mettre un
terme à la protection de la politique
agricole commune
apportez à nos agriculteurs et il
fallait mener combat nous l'avons fait
pour éviter que l'agriculture ne soit
traité comme les autres secteurs dans
ces négociations dites du gatt
il fallait une négociation spécial la
concession dramatique qui a provoqué
tout le reste est de la fin de l'année
1986 sous l'autorité de monsieur jacques
chirac
votre ami c'est depuis qu'on a été
coincé et que la réforme de la pac en
effet n'est pas parfaite mais qui ne
mérite pas ce que vous en dites parce
qu'elle a été en plus compromise par
l'accord de blair house sur lequel nous
avons nous censurer la commission cette
réforme elle résulte de la pression qui
vient de là et la faute initiale elle
est là en plus il ajoute qu'il fallait
en effet corriger la mauvaise
négociation de la communauté de la
commission à blair house négociations ou
la commission outre passé ses pouvoirs
j'en suis convaincu maintenant que nous
avons pas si l'augmentation passionnant
cyclables sont inquiètes et à ses
mollets et vénissieux d'agriculture
monsieur louis blanc ce que j'ai
toujours en auvergne personnages dans
des pubs pierrot je regarde ça et la gtz
et ya sept français qui m'a laissé quand
même rêveur c'est daté du 22 mai 92 il
dit là vous transmets une note sur
l'accord intervenu sur la réforme de la
politique agricole commune il parle pas
de plaire à tout prix quoi il dit cette
réforme est très positive pour
l'agriculture française et européenne
valait dire ça de l'agriculteur il était
pour l'europe
ils sont contre l'europe mauvais coup
pour l'europe deuxième mauvais coup pour
l'europe c'est ce que vous venez de dire
à propos de l'élargissement
vous avez dit moi je suis pour
l'entraidé 4 ce candidat devant sony
socialiste on verra plus tard
et vous dites dans un interview aux
échos des rois j'ai donné un terreau où
le land à nous suivons dans ses journaux
je suis partisan d'une extension du vote
à la majorité et je les dis à mes amis
norvégiens suédois finlandais autrichien
bon ces quatre pays vont entrer ces
quatre pays vont prendre et heureuse
la france ça combien de droits de vote
la france a pas tout à fait le cas des
droits de vote selon un barème de droits
de vote quand on vote et d'émilie c'est
quand on va au tournant on vote avec un
nombre de voix la france à combien de
voix au conseil européen
si votre haleine c'est vous qui êtes
candidat cette fois mois en plus les
quatre nations européennes france
allemagne angleterre italie aujourd'hui
ensemble ont la majorité
bien sûr elle va être préservé non mais
c'est très important
illustrée dans des positions français
qui sont pas je refais précisé phrase et
je mets pas candidat nous avons dix voix
quand vous êtes au conseil des ministres
est conduit en prose est adoptée par la
majorité simple majorité qualifiée on
compte les voix par pays la france
à divo un bond à la d'ivoire les quatre
pays qui vont rentrer ils ont une
population qui est moitié moins de la
nôtre ils font au total 44 % de notre
population
ils vont avoir combien de voix sur le
coeur non ils vont savoir 14 euros vous
fait entrer ou à chacun non non vous
trompez anormal à l'entraînement je
prends à témoin je regrette mon geste
est de l'île ils vont l'avoir 14 voix et
un changement de se battre à proposer un
tout quand on vote rend bouhdid folle
vote à la majorité
les quatre nouveaux mondes clientes vont
avoir à voter surtout la politique
agricole commune la fiscalité le budget
ils ont une population que la moitié
moins de la nôtre ils vont avoir 14
voilà on en a dit moi je dis c'est pas
acceptable
et c'est la raison pour laquelle je ne
voterai pas la ratification dans ces
conditions là et la faute a été commise
par le gouvernement socialiste
car hier une idée qu'on connaissait bien
qui était de dire il faut élargir notre
question mais pour élargir faut adapter
des institutions vous n'allez pas donner
plus de droits à ceux qui hantent que
ceux qui sont déjà jusqu'en 1991 tout le
monde était d'accord pour dire on va
réformer les institutions prennent
élargira bien et c'est au conseil
européen de lisbonne
un show prix général s'était pas vous
c'était président mitterrand qui a
dissocié la réforme des institutions et
l'élargissement etc a dit qu'il finit
par les autres chefs d'états ou billets
attendu mais nous avons une position
française jeudi ce jour là on a porté un
mauvais coup alors parce que c'est
inacceptable pour le pignon le jour les
français vont découvrir que des pays qui
hante
moitié de notre population d'en avoir
plus de voix quand on notera que nous eh
bien non c'est une situation
inacceptable pour nous faire et c'est la
raison pour laquelle je demande que les
futurs élargissements fois précédée par
la réforme des articles sont repris la
même somme au tarif allant des weasley
ce parce que vous êtes jeunes demandent
aussi que les futurs gisements sera
précédée par la réforme des institutions
j'hésitais sur un mauvais je vais le
dire tout de même il ya beaucoup
d'hypocrisie dans ce que vous venez de
dire monsieur giscard d'estaing vous
savez très bien que l'abandon de
l'approfondissement de cette réforme
avant l'élargissement elle est due aux
conservateurs anglais les hommes de la
liste de monsieur baudis ont siégé dans
le même groupe parlementaire que ils
sont vos amis
c'est eux qui ont tout bloqué et
d'ailleurs vous n'avez pas fait
d'objection l adhésion de la grande
bretagne quand elle s'est présentée
alors que tout le monde savait qu'elle
jouerait temps qu'elle était
conservatrice un jeu différent
dieu merci d'ailleurs nos amis
travailliste anglais ont fait le choix
européen
franchement est fortement maintenant
alors les choses sont très claires
premièrement on a bâti pour sortir de
sanaa ces mauvais compromis mais qui
permit unis le dinar porte le nom mais
qui permet en effet de maintenir un une
limitation des minorités de blocage
et surtout je me bats autour d'une
proposition que je voudrais inclure dans
la constitution de l'europe c'est qu'il
y ait un vote à la matca vote ne soit
valable parce qu'il représente à la fois
la majorité des états et la majorité de
la population à merouana position dans
laquelle je me bats pour sortir de
linguistes et c'est formidable parce que
cela figure dans la proposition de l'idf
et scénariste quelques choses avancent
s'opposer nous en provenance d'autres un
député qui est un des lots tels
jean-louis bourlanges un excellent
député très assidu au parlement européen
pour parler de la civilité si vous
voulez qui a proposé que dans l'avenir
il ya la majorité de la population et la
majorité des états suivant des règles
savais qu'il frappait l'envi sa beauté à
l'heure actuelle vous approuvez annacone
donc ça serait bien aussi conservé sa
gym dérivant chez delhaize maire dé fond
d'un lac au sli oc monsieur giscard
d'estaing quand il a touché beaucoup et
l'adhésion de la grèce ne s'est pas posé
tant de problèmes sur la manière ça
allait marcher pourtant l'écart de
niveau de vie c'était beaucoup plus
compliqué il a accepté l'arrivée de la
grande bretagne 100 m de conditions de
procédure ni d'approfondissement des
règles et il devient hostile au moment
où arrivent des pays à faible chômage
forte protection sociale et dont la
direction était souvent social-démocrate
le ruban à rieumes andré collard et d
hoffenheim pays et ses petits pays
profitent de la tipp heureusement bêta à
l'origine pour leur donner un poids
beaucoup plus important que le nôtre et
je dis que ce n'est pas raisonnable pour
les français le jour les français vont
découvrir qu'ils n'ont plus de poids que
nous avec une population moitié moins
vous verrez la réaction de clients de
services câblés je la comprends je
répondrai que c'est un excellent membre
essayer de faire un tour d'horizon plus
le plus vaste possible sur l'arrivée
éventuelle des anciens pays de l'est
est ce que vous êtes favorable au
principe dans quel délai et à quelles
conditions rapidement sobrement
rapidement en mai à rodez avant
finalement de retard pour voir la classe
prioritaire parce que sinon cette
affaire va capoter comprendre ça la
tâche prioritaire c'est d'achever
l'organisation de l'union européenne
pouvait pas à la fois avoir organiser
quelque chose quoi que ce soit et en
même temps faire entrer indéfiniment
nouveaux membres
ce prêt d une association sportive un
clavelin porte quoi avant d'avoir new
roman wick 6e ses statuts alors nous ont
toujours pas fixé les statuts et the
dial heure actuelle plus d'élargissement
tant que les statuts l'ont pas été prêt
pourquoi pas une loi fondamentale pour
une constitution sur de l'union
européenne
première chose deuxième jour vocation à
nous rejoindre l'avenir s'ils acceptent
bien sûr les règles de l'association et
du club qu'il faut simplement qu'il
accepte les règles de fonctionnement et
dans l'intervalle nous devons nous
occuper d'eux dans le cadre d'un système
d'association de façon à réduire autant
que possible les cards leurs conditions
de vie par rapport aux priorités achevée
l'organisation c'était l'union de
l'europe tant qu'on n'aura pas fait ça
pas de nouveaux élargissements
mais en même temps une politique très
active de réduction des écarts de niveau
de vie entre eux et nous améliorer les
règles de l'europe c'est une nécessité
c'est un des rares points sur lesquels
nous sommes d'accord mais aujourd'hui
l'europe est impuissante aussi bien en
bosnie devant le chômage c'est parce
qu'elle sait pas ce qu'elle est libérale
et pour la clarification des choses il
faut une volonté politique
je dis moi que le choix c'est un choix
droite gauche où on accepte georges du
marché ce que fait la droite ce que font
les libéraux où on affirme une volonté
de gauche c'est à dire une volonté
d'initiative une volonté de donner une
absolue priorité au combat contre le
chômage reste de faible importance si on
ne mène pas l'europe en rade déconsidéré
et affaibli il voilà pourquoi je sais
que les nouveaux pieri qui arrivent
comme ce seront ceux sont les meilleurs
sur le plan de la bataille contre le
chômage
ils soutiendront les initiatives
auxquelles je pense ils renforceront une
europe de gauche une europe solidaire
c'est bien ça que nous voulons
on a demandé à nos téléspectateurs de
nous envoyer des questions parmi intel
et pour vous montrer que ce système
fonctionne et que c'est pas du tout truc
qui soit le poser une question qui nous
a été posée par cyrille fournier qui
était étudiant en vingt ans après les
nombreux cessez-le-feu bafoués en bosnie
joey nuit à mon prêt dit-il sa totale
impuissance à régler ce conflit
pierre elle a désormais perdu toute
crédibilité aux yeux de nombreux
européens alors quelle est votre opinion
à vous deux
quant à la création d'un conseil de
sécurité européen est ce qu'on a
vraiment besoin de l'onu pour traiter
d'un problème qui ne concerne à limites
que les européens voyez il était un peu
en avance trop non alors michel rocard
y'a pas piège dire le droit des nations
dire la paix ou la guerre ne peut
appartenir qu'à la communauté
internationale tout entière
je suis chaudement partisans parce que
l'europe se dote d'une politique
étrangère et de sécurité commune c'est
un des résultats positifs du traité de
maastricht que de pouvoir la mettre en
place et nous avons besoin à l'appui de
cette politique étrangère commune de
forcer armes et intégrer le record en
est un en brillant il est franco
allemand il va défiler et je crois que
c'est une bonne chose et s'y joindront
bientôt des belges et des espagnols il
faut qu'il soit au service des missions
de paix proposé par l'onu
je ne pense pas qu'il soit bon que un
sous groupe de nations fassent la paix
sur son continent
sans la garde du conseil de sécurité des
nations du des nations unies qui même
s'ils marchent mal est la seule autorité
compétente mais je souhaite que le rap
et les moyens de l'appliquer de telles
résolutions en bosnie qu'est ce qui
manque
une phase qui menace les serbes et qui
les met sous la menace de sanctions
dures militaire nous sommes dans une
situation dramatique où les massacres
continue parce que l'europe n'est pas
capable d'aligner cette force et que les
américains trop loin ne le veulent pas
c'est pas c'est pas un manque de conseil
de sécurité européen qui fait le
problème
l'impuissance de l'europe ont choisi est
une honte
c'est une honte qui pèse sur nous tous
et sur cette élection
parmi les gens qui n'iront pas voter et
donc ils écoutaient bon on nous demande
de voter pour que ce n'est même pas
capable de traiter un problème qui est à
nos portes et doit nous voyons le des
affreuses conséquente
donc c'est une honte comme l'a dit
d'ailleurs là dessus mais c'est le cas
il ya deux niveaux il ya le niveau
international qui est quand poteau sous
quelle forme décider d'une intervention
militaire à l'extérieur l'extérieur et
là il faut voir qu'on ne peut pas le
faire contre l'avis des russes qu'on ne
peut pas faire une il rend la vie des
américains
donc s'il doit y avoir une décision une
opération militaire importante
il est normal qu'elle soit débattue au
sein du conseil de sécurité de l'onu
mais
dix ans puisque ces décisions de l'onu
elle le mène en vain
par contre alors ce qui est choquant
c'est qu'à partir du moment où une
action et décidé
l'europe est incapable de la conduire
elle est incapable de la conduire à deux
niveaux incapable de la conduire au
niveau politique parce qu'elle ne prend
pas des décisions d'actions ensemble est
incapable de l'accomplir sur le terrain
parce qu'elle n'a pas les moyens
militaires de logistique et vent et ça
c'est une situation inacceptable et
dangereuse parce qu'elle leur actuelle
elle se présente en bosnie qui est
appelée de dimension limitée même si son
drame est épouvantable mais il peut y
avoir à l'est de l'europe un jour des
déstabilisations beaucoup plus grande et
on découvrira que l'inexistence cette
capacité de décider et que l'aîné
l'inexistant ce moyen d'agir enfin
présente une menace pour la sécurité de
l'europe
alors dans ce domaine il faut bien
entendu avancer très vite je te reste à
vous est fait état dans la presse vous
avez vous avez dit si j'ai bien lu que
vous vous interrogiez sur l'opportunité
de la présence de leur corps lors du
défilé du 14 juillet c'est pour des
raisons
j'allais dire sentimentale des raisons
purement près cause des bonbons je suis
pour la réconciliation qu'on nous poser
cette question je réponds très propre
membres on ne fait pas de calculs en
fait à faire quand j'étais lycéen paris
tous les matins en se réveillant on
entendait les allemands ça m'émeut qui
chantait sous nos fenêtres
on en trouve l est pas dans la jusqu'en
44 et bien l'idée que la néo commémore
même ses combats ses sacrifices
nous allons avoir défilé sur les champs
elysées ça me fait quelque chose que
vous soyez un ardent défenseur de la
réconciliation en quad il ya des lieux
pour la réconciliation
il y a des moments pour le fou rire chez
montage
je crois qu'il faut savoir concilier la
réconciliation et le souvenir
il faut pas oublier que cette europe que
nous défendons avec des visions
différentes nick nous défendons tous
deux elle est née de la volonté de
mettre fin à la guerre elle est née au
lendemain de la guerre à cause de la
guerre et c'est pour ça que c'est la
belle et grande aventure de nos
générations
je ne sais pas ce qui se serait passé si
nous menions pas dans l'union européenne
avec une france et une allemagne ayant
au début du conflit yougoslave des
politiques étrangères qui ont mis du
temps à s'accorder qui sont partis avec
des divergences je ne sais pas où nous
en serions nous devons déjà l'europe 50
ans de paix et c'est au nom même du
refus de la guerre que moi je suis en
fonction même du souvenir heureux parce
que j'ai eu les mêmes deux motions mon
père était n'était pas en france enfin
le débarquement c'est une immense
affaire et perquisitions allemande au
domicile dans ma famille tous et nous
avons tous vécu tout cela tout cela est
affreux mais au moins débarrassons nous
en est encore pauvre on dans le souvenir
la nécessité de la réconciliation
mais je reconnais que nous sommes en
sensibilité l'ouest un petit peu moins
de cette affaire de nos enfants que
d'espérer que la paix soit consolidée et
nous devons dominer nos souvenirs c'est
un petit peu moins de sept minutes il ya
encore 5 de deux points qui serait bon
de d'aborder rapidement parce que pour
une fois ce sont des dossiers qui sont
quelques toutefois un petit peu abscons
pour les téléspectateurs
est-ce que selon vous il faut un
président pour l'europe
et est ce que l'europe doit être fédéral
tire en gros par le système des états
unis est évident qu'il faut à présent
pour l'europe ça fait des années que le
dit d'ailleurs rodier c'est ce qu'a dit
s'abstient votre présidence d'europe
pour du tout c'est parce qu'il est
évident qu'il faut un président pour
l'europe alors la stupéfaction
il ya quelques jours de leur a dit la
même chose
jusque-là enduisent elle c'est une
fantaisie de lits médiation maintenant
tout le monde y vient et pourquoi parce
que on peut pas avoir un ensemble de 340
millions d'habitants qui n'est pas
identifiée sur la scène internationale
qui ne peut pas s'exprimer de façon
continue régulière donc il faut un
président pour combien de temps on verra
bien désigné par qui là au début par le
conseil européen qui choisit
un président est donc ça c'était soit
dans nos rêves et de niveau 10 d'avoir
abjuré en quelque sorte sa foi
fédéraliste pour rassurer
là dessus aussi moins très clair pour
des histoires incompréhension quand vous
mettez des états ensemble qui se donne
des institutions par exemple un
parlement un conseil est que ces
institutions peuvent prendre des
décisions il ya des directives et ainsi
de suite c'est un système de type
fédéral
autrement dit on fait de fédéralistes
sont venus dire à l'heure actuelle la
querelle n'est pas sur le fédéralisme
elle est sur la question de savoir si ça
doit être un fédéralisme centralisateur
unificateur comme aux états unis cercle
pour le faire que tout le pays vit à peu
près de la même manière toutes les
grandes décisions sont centralisées oui
si ça doit être un fédéraliste très
décentralisée et respectueux des
identités des cultures nationales je fus
pour cette deuxième forme de fédéralisme
aucun depuis l'origine pour une
fédération de nation ce qui correspond à
peu près à ce que vous venez de décrire
j'ai donc moelle avantage de n'avoir pas
eu à renoncer à mes propres convictions
je suis un peu effrayé des renoncements
successifs de monsieur baudis
il a renoncé ou fédéralisme tel qu'il le
voyait il est en train de courir de rire
le rpr cette liste rpr et l'udf par
rapport à la nôtre un homme une femme
c'est pas le même projet d'avenir on à
l'alternance qu'on peut mais en tout cas
ça fait que la liste de monsieur baudis
comporte un tiers de militants de la
cause anti européenne c'est très clair
et c'est dramatique
moi je maintiens ma ligne et je trouve
que dans cette affaire il ya des
orphelins de l'europe
la vision d'une europe qui partage
vraiment les souverainetés et qui soit
efficace
elle est un peu absente dans cette
affaire et au fond je me sens en
situation d'appeler à tous ceux qui
veulent mettre fin à la purification
ethnique que l'europe se bat contre le
chômage et que l'europe construise son
champ social qu'on construise une europe
solidaire pour le rendez vous n'avait
plus vraiment qu'une liste que là dedans
l'europe est un président ça me paraît
nécessaire aussi c'est une évidence mais
ça ne règle pas tout le problème
institutionnel qui joue bien davantage
sur la clarté des choix politiques
some gauche contre droite maintenant le
temps du combat des européens contre les
nationalistes dans chacun de nos pays
qui a été nécessaire très longtemps pour
mettre en place cette europe contre des
volontés nationales notamment très
présente en france ce temps est finie
l'europe et ses institutions sont en
place et c'est irréversible
nous avons maintenant la chance de
pouvoir lui donner un axe politique
claire et en europe comme en france les
choix sont différents entre la gauche et
la droite c'est aussi simple que cela
moi je veux une robe debout et une
europe sociale nous allons devoir
conclure est ce que je voulais
simplement vous demander monsieur
giscard d'estaing vraiment en dix
minutes
qu'est ce que vous pouvez dire aux
français qui justement vous y faisiez
allusion tout à l'heure n'ont pas envie
d'aller voter dimanche m'écouter ses
traits d'abord que ces choses sont
beaucoup plus simples on leur dit
d'abord le choix que d michel rocard qui
est un choix en effet rentrer une europe
socialiste et une europe libérale la
france est débarrassé du socialisme il
ya un an france elle peut pas le
réintroduire en europe donc faut trop
bas en europe libyen mais surtout dans
les élections vous avez des élections
qui sont pour tout de suite
vous avez sont cantonales c'est pour
tout de suite vous avez des élections
qui sont pour le moyen terme comment le
pays va gouverner c'est les élections
législatives l'année dernière puis les
élections qui façonnent l'avenir auprès
de la bière c'est loin on s'en fiche on
a bien plus tard et finalement l'avenir
c'est quelque chose qui s'avance comme
un grand fleuve et puis si on prend une
nouvelle direction on prend une mauvaise
direction et moi je trouve que cette
année où on voi horreurs du passé leurs
robes qu'au fond c'est ça toutes ces
émissions et on se dit que peut-être on
a la chance d'ouvrir un avenir tout à
fait différent pour l'europe
je crois que ça c'est un très grand
enjeu est donc moi je demande aux
françaises et aux français de voter pour
la liste udf rta pour que l'europe
libérale de voter dans cette élection
pour que l'europe puisse être pour le
sexe dans le sac prochain grand
continent pacifique apaisé et moderne
merci messieurs juste un mot pour
conclure je n'ai pas eu à aller si
vraiment on va vendre parce qu'on va
devoir augmenter d'un mot très rapide
l'europe a besoin d'être debout je
représente dans ce combat la seule liste
qui est la même plateforme la même
volonté que 15 autres partis socialistes
et sociaux démocrates
sur l'ensemble de l'europe
notre volonté est claire nous voulons
une europe solidaire et cette chance
d'avoir une majorité de gauche au
parlement européen car c'est possible il
faut pas laisser échapper
c'est grâce à cela qu enfin nous
pourrons nous battre sérieusement contre
le chômage
on vient d'avoir une présentation
admirable de la résignation devant le
chômage ce n'est pas notre hypothèse
nous avons besoin d'une majorité de
gauche au parlement
merci messieurs soyez juste une toute la
question c'est est ce que j'aurai le
plaisir de vous retrouver dans un an
pour les présidentielles vous avez
confirmé
l'autre fois dans la presse que vous
étiez candidat jusqu'au bout vous pouvez
nous répéter ce soir je dirais que les
choses sont plus claires dans mon corps
dont celui de monsieur giscard d'estaing
non monsieur giscard d'estaing vous avez
dit l'autre jour chez nos confrères de
france 3 je ferai part de mes projets
pour la france pour la période 95 et
l'an 2000 et comme par hasard c'est un
quinquennat il ça a été interprété vous
le savez bien parce que vous lisez les
journaux comme une pré déclaration de
candidature du tout j'ai dit quelque
chose de très simple et fraîche prépare
dans les projets est-ce que ça va être
une période formidable 95 l'an 2000
vous allez voir ce que ça va être tendu
bill pour les français ils vont voir
tout à coup quelque chose qui soude de
banlieue qui va leur faire peur et que
vous êtes très nouveau et donc la france
d'avoir à faire un choix très important
je souhaite que les idées que je
représente soit pour le coup dans ce
départ à je prenais ça sert pour cela
merci beaucoup monsieur je rappelle que
demain nous organisons la rédaction de
france 2 organise un grand débat avec
les neuf responsables des principales
listes engagées aux européennes débat
qui commencera à 20h50 et je vous
rappelle que vous pouvez poser vos
questions par le 36 15 codes france 2
nous transmettrons ces questions aux
différents candidats et ceux qui mènent
les listes demain dans les 4 vérités à
7h50 gérard leclerc recevra jean-marie
le pen qui lui aussi candidat à minuit
dernier journal présenté par catherine
ceylac donc demain à 20h vous
retrouverez etienne leenhardt en ce jour
de saint médard
il devrait pleuvoir ce soir et cette
nuit météo france prévoit en effet des
orages localement forts météo complète
dans quelques instants avec sophie
davant
merci encore une fois messieurs merci de
nous avoir écoutés très très bonne
soirée
à demain